But right now, major breaking news in the sports world,...
...King James is the new points king of the NBA.
Los Angeles Lakers superstar, LeBron James,...
...has just become the league's all-time leading scorer.
James scoring 36 points tonight so far.
The game is still going on.
What he has done is passed fellow Laker legend Kareem Abdul-Jabbar...
...to claim the record, which Abdul-Jabbar held since 1984...
...and who's in attendance for tonight's game.
What that moment was like?
Honestly, watching the aftermath of that moment right now...
...is incredibly surreal.
Everybody here in the arena was on their feet, waiting,...
...in bated breath for the anticipation of that shot going in.
And it was one of his signature fade away shots going from the left elbow.
And he absolutely drained it.
Ran back towards center court with his hands up in the air.
His entire family, his close friends, cheering him on.
They're now on the court with him, celebrating,...
...embracing, some of them feel, or look, I should say, very emotional in this moment.
It's a record that many people never thought would be broken.
We're talking more than 38,000 career points at the highest level of basketball...
...over the course of an NBA career that spanned 20 years for LeBron James.
And now he stands at center court as fans chant "MVP" as the arena plays a montage...
...of what is essentially him collecting Infinity Stones..
...over the course of his career.
And it could not be a more proud moment for the fans,...
...for his family looking on from right in front of him,...
...and, of course, for the NBA, as Kareem now embraces him,...
...passing one milestone, handing it off to the next generation.